for both genders is Dr Andrew Stanton
from Southwest Medical part of the Optum
Network the sponsors of this segment
doctor thank you for being here today
thank you very much for having me the
stats are interesting that they show
that men do have a shorter life
expectancy compared to women they do
indeed actually it's interesting you say
that so A really common knowledge I
guess is that men have a shorter life
for several obvious reasons if anyone's
uh got any boy children of course right
right that being said men on average
live about uh in the United States 60 or
76.2 years women about 81.8 and that's a
very big discrepancy between the two of
them I mean that's a five-year
difference
and a lot of that is is because well men
in general we just we don't necessarily
take as good a care of ourselves as
maybe we should sometimes and is it
possible that men don't handle stress as
well oh very very true you know mental
health is something that's obviously a
Hot Topic in the United States today and
I would argue that that's something that
is really
um very important for men in particular
a lot of times men don't really feel
comfortable I guess and maybe talking
about their feelings or things like that
maybe because of how it is that they
were raised and so mental health is
something that's incredibly important
and if you don't have the appropriate
ways to handle stress then maybe you
look to some of the the bad coping
mechanisms you know things like alcohol
or sleep anxiety that may not
necessarily help you too much in terms
of having a long and healthy life right
just push those feelings down yeah
exactly right don't let them out I was
surprised to read the stats of the
causes of death and in the top three now
is covet 19.
um you know I I don't have any numbers
in front of me so I guess I can't really
give you a solid answer on that one I
mean covet is definitely still out there
so obviously please stay safe get
vaccinated uh you know do the
appropriate things to really kind of
avoid any unnecessary infection right
but you know in terms of overall health
in general what we really look at is
this preventive measures I'm a really
big fan of announcement prevention is
worth a pound of cure right so you know
things that you can do actually men and
women in particular actually according
to the American Academy of Family
Physicians we recommend about 150
minutes of exercise a week that's two
and a half hours it doesn't have to be
two and a half hours in a row right it
can be 10 minutes here 10 minutes there
sure um you know vigorous exercise a
brisk walk something that's really
simple to do uh slight bit of weight
training taking your dog out uh you know
just kind of getting the blood pump and
it's a really good thing you mentioned
resistance training or weight training
and I've heard that that is an
especially good way to combat bone
density problems it is actually it's one
of the recommendations that we give in
battling bone density problems which is
something that plague a lot of uh older
older adults and weight training in
particular now I'm not asking people to
go out and join an Ironman Triathlon or
I guess become a Mr Universe so to speak
right but it is a pretty important thing
in terms of even just a little bit of
weight you know over a short period of
time is something that can definitely
show some benefits in terms of
maintaining bone density and making sure
that you don't end up actually with
brittle bones Dr Stan thanks so much for
being here today great tips and great
information really appreciate it thank
you and thanks again to Southwest
Medical for sponsoring this segment they
have locations across Nevada if you want
more information call that number right
there
702-877-5199 or
visit that website we'll be right back